welcome back y'all our next guest spent
decades singing dancing and acting on
stage and screen now she is focusing on
other more personal Pursuits like being
a children's author her second book is
called see you on the other side and
it's all about helping kids cope with
change and grief everybody please
welcome back to the show Rachel Montes
[Applause]
[Music]
Miner
[Applause]
nice to see you again how are you I am
amazing New York looks good on you girl
thank you I love it here so much I do
it's like giving me a whole new life I
love it that's what I wanted so thank
you God Universe for that York how how
is your hubby how's Ricky how's your
daughter Ricky is amazing we just came
off doing the Kennedy Center I was like
he's been doing around I've been seeing
him everywhere you know Ricky whenever
there's music I know and the Emmys he
was nominated and yeah just getting
ready for like the Clive Davis preg
gramy oh my gosh my daughter's five now
and it's the most amazing time this
holiday season was like we were in
perfect cuteness for Christmas it was
like the perfect it was five she was
really believing it was amazing oh I
love that and then they opened the pr
it's just more magical with kids too I
feel like just I don't know it ignites
like that kid in all of us like she told
me Santa came but Rudolph couldn't make
it I was like I was like he didn't make
it yeah yeah no but Santa came she like
I was really bummed I love that okay so
wait the book I think is very important
because talking about grief loss death
anything like that with kids like I
remember my daughter started I think
around like four like really talking
about like what where did they go what
does this mean and then then it starts
to freak them out the older they get I
think this is such an important book so
it's called see you on the other side so
how did this concept hit you like why
it came to me in a dream like the first
one yes oh right on just like the sun
the moon and the stars that came to me
in a dream and that was more about our
connection to the universe yeah this
one's about our connection to each other
and how Love Never Ends yeah yeah I tell
my daughter that I I tell it's more my
daughter that gets freaked out about it
right now I just known of my son is more
Loof about it but it really it terrifies
them at first and I remember we remember
when you were a kid you found out and
you were like wait what like what
happens and and it can be terrifying so
it's so important not just for kids this
book but also for parents to buy to
start the conversation with their kids
yes and it's really is a tool to help
for any time of change you know it
teaches us that change is natural and it
really connects us to this power that
love just goes on and on and it's
Everlasting yeah did something happen
within your family or something H like
was there loss in your family to where
it kind of triggered that for you to
write something um my grandmother and I
were very very close she lived to be 96
and she was a huge part of my great
genetics there I like that yeah she
that's she's probably 95 there can you
believe that skin I know but she used to
take me to Mir Woods we would travel
together to national parks and my
parents both worked full-time jobs so
she was a big part of my childhood and
farmers markets and dance class yeah so
yeah I mean it came to me in a dream but
maybe like subconsciously because nature
is such a big part of the book and
teaching them that change is a part of
nature so I feel like you know maybe
that was her working through me and in
some of the spreads you know in order to
connect with the people we love like I
like to cook the same recipes I made
with her or we go on the same walks or
go to the same Beach yeah you know what
kind of keeping them alive in a sense it
is it is and there's lots of like real
examples in the spreads about how to
connect to those we love and and keep
that connection going but in a very like
uplifting and soothing and positive way
and what a gift to give our children
that you know change is it's natural and
it's and it's positive and we can stay
connected to all of those that we love
yeah agree it's a constant conversation
I have with so thank you for the book
everybody Rachel's new book is called
see you on the other side it's out now
get it wherever you get your
[Music]
[Applause]
books thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home